hi YouTube my name is Tamra chambers and
this is Tamra's never seemed happy
topper fest today I am watching the 1968
horror classic Rosemary's Baby I love
horror films
I love being scared and I think that
they are a blast when done well alas
there is not much content for us horror
lovers that doesn't end in
disappointment and sadness I'm
interested to see how a movie from 1968
horror wise holds up I've heard that it
is pretty fucked up I am looking forward
to it and I'm looking forward to a full
month of fun horror
I love October with all of my heart
let's start Rosemary's babies
predictions and then I was not getting
very many predictions so I thought maybe
this was a terrible idea that I have
chosen an awful choice that I decided to
stick with it alright I'll keep with
Rosemary's Baby
very excited towba first yes oh good why
have I not seen this yet the story and
the acting were so good not scary my
heart wasn't racing but it was stressful
and very thriller esque I've got my
partly black cat right here
good story is about rosemary who's
married to this actor they live in New
York they want to have a child they move
into this new apartments and things
start going awry though neighbors are
creepy a lot of weird things happen with
the pregnancy and in the end you know
tables all this time turns out she had
Satan's baby everything right now
currently 2017 is very culty which she
like witches are very in style and so it
still the story still is very engaging
it still holds up really well the acting
was incredible she is so damn delightful
I thought she was incredible I don't
know what else she's been in I could
look it up not going to my first very
first impression of her was that I was
going to think she was a little too like
kind of cutesy Tootsie she's a variant
like cutesy voice I first I wasn't like
super into it she just proved me so
wrong she's awesome and badass and
perfect casting for this so you decided
I'm moving into this place and their
friend tells them about all these
terrible things that have happened in
that building they're like it's fine
it's fine we're just gonna raise a kid
here it's not a big deal but then they
move in and they start putting a lot of
money into this place they're renting
right they know that doesn't go back to
them at the end right they're like
painting and adding doors and sconces
and just they know that right that is
the true horror of this film it's the
money that they're not gonna get back
the place is really nice and at first I
was wondering how this unsuccessful
actor husband was supporting them both
and paying for this place but you find
out like he's in a bunch of commercials
and yeah because to where all the money
is so I guess he wants to be in film I
understand it's not artistically
fulfilling but paying the bills
I would know my last commercial was
crying over a spilled milkshake
you know what that was artistically
fulfilling so that are there for a while
the neighbors are really nosy they keep
giving them weird food chocolate mouse
seems suspicious then I just wrote wait
is she having sex with Satan okay so
let's talk she wakes up from having been
drugged for a sex cult kind of ordeal
with scratches all over her from Satan
himself and the excuse that her husband
gives her is well it was fun in a
necrophilia type of way that's what
you're going with
I don't necessarily know what I would
have said instead of that excuse but
literally anything else you fell on
knives it was I it was I could swear it
was like I made a pact with the devil
and our coltie crazy nut so neighbors
but you're pregnant
BAM so she finds out she's pregnant and
she's stoked cuz she's been wanting to
get pregnant just probably I'm guessing
not by Satan but you know I don't know
so she's at the doctor's office getting
her blood drawn and Yanks it takes a lot
for me to get squeamish about needles
I am a type one diabetic and I take
injections every single day multiple
times but this did the trick she's
getting her blood drawn and first of all
it's not even in a vein it's like right
here and then they put the needle in and
like like angle it I wrote oh my god I
love her haircut I was contemplating
getting my hair cut what if what if I
film the first half of the reaction with
long hair and then right here I would
cut go get my hair cut into a pixie cut
and then come back and I realized that
what's not worth it at all
so the friend from beginning who told
them not to move into the place comes
over and he's like you look terrible and
she does and he's like your neighbors
kind of weird and he is and he's like
all of this is pretty suspicious and it
totally is
so Rosemary's in a ton of pain and it's
definitely from the weird mucus
milkshake that she's drinking every
morning from her neighbors and her
suspicious new baby doctor and
everything sucks so hutch is like can
you meet me I have some information you
might want to hear so she goes she's in
like a ton of pain she's okay pain begun
I will have no more oh my god same then
I wrote hutch is in a coma okay well I'm
gonna punch a mold people do you find
out that the husband is allowed this to
happen so that his career will flourish
and it's so shitty she gets wise to
everything that's happening and she's
like I'm not gonna drink that drink
he knowingly is like no you should drink
it drink up and it's so frustrating and
it just gets under your skin you feel so
so helpless with her and for her and
it's so bad she pieces together
everything finds out that the name of
her neighbor is an anagram for this
Satan book and it's awesome she gets
ambushed by all the neighbors in her
apartment and she goes into labor and
it's so stressful then there's this
whole montage of her going in and out of
consciousness and she's like it's the
baby around and they're like yeah and
then she wakes up again she's like it's
the baby around there like it died and
then she goes into depression and her
husband is like wow you really went
through some crazy postpartum stuff it's
okay we'll have another kid hopefully it
won't be crazy this time right then she
sneaks into the neighbor's place finds
her baby knows that it's Satan now with
this amazing crib it's truly a crib fit
for Satan's child 10 out of 10 would
recommend you don't get to see the kid
which sucks because she says this cool
line about what did you do to his eyes
awesome would love to see it but then
again 1968 probably better that we
didn't see it at the very end it cuts
before you can see if she's decided if
she's going to take care of his baby or
not it's so good
Wow I loved that film I'm so glad
then I saw I'm also really glad that I
waited to see it until now so I can like
spew my happy emotions onto camera loved
it
you will still understand why people
were comparing mother to Rosemary's Baby
a lot of people did compare the two I
don't really get it but also I don't get
a lot of things that might just be me if
you don't love it I'm gonna be very
upset such a phenomenal horror film
agreed and don't be upset because I
loved it you'll think Rosemary's pixie
cut doesn't really suit her also how
does it struggling after afford a place
like that in New York I do think it
suits her and commercial work damn but
there's some money in commercial work
prediction you'll be disgusted / uneasy
with guy statement that his offense
against rosemary was kind of fun in a
necrophile sort of way definitely
definitely definitely the whole rape it
intense I just think that he could have
handled it in in such a different way
like not let Satan rape his wife you'll
appreciate the movie but you'll have
major qualms once you look into what a
detestable piece-of-shit Roman Polanski
is who when he was for Poland was
invaded by Nazi German Polanski spent
the next six years of his childhood
don't see on his own trying to survive
the ongoing Holocaust turning port in
his life took place in 1969 when his
pregnant wife Sharon Tate and four
friends were brutally murdered by
members of the Manson Family in 1977
Polanski was arrested and charged with
raping a thirteen-year-old girl he fled
to Paris before sentencing then to
continue to make films The Pianist
Adrien Brody what are you doing what why
Adrien it's always weird when you find
out the people that you like work from
our monsters you monsters I just saw the
film for the first time recently and was
surprised at how genuinely creepy it is
poorer done right in my opinion I so
agree it's creepy it gets under your
skin
the story is spot-on they don't show too
much I think if they would have shown I
wanted to see the baby let us be clear
but I think it
may have ruined it kind of like the
signs thing don't show us the alien
ruins it what do you all think I should
watch next week monster squad scream
poltergeist Cannibal Holocaust without
the brutality towards animals what do
you think I will probably put a pull-up
on my Twitter page follow me at Tamara L
chambers on Twitter I will see y'all
next week for another damn Joker fest it
was Ike I there he goes the scoundrel
[Music]
[Applause]
you